[Music]
indian film star deepika padukone
is taking a stand for mental health
as the pandemic rages she's raising
awareness of psychiatric problems
and the ways people can get help
thousands are dying every day in india
as it experiences the biggest wave of
coronavirus infections the world has
seen the healthcare system is in danger
of collapse
and millions are suffering from anxiety
and depression
deepika padukone is urging people to get
help
she set up the live love laugh
foundation it helps connect people with
mental health services like
telephone hotlines and suicide
prevention centers
she says no life should be lost to
mental illness
[Music]
i'm rob watts in berlin welcome to this
dw coveted 19 special
now india has reported more than 20
million cases
of covered 19. although the actual
figure may
be much higher than that as well as the
immense physical toll
of the pandemic it's also putting
enormous strain on the mental health of
indians
lockdowns death illness and job
insecurity
all have an impact on how people feel
breakdowns fear anxiety these are the
words 29 year old kanika
uses when asked about how she's coping
with the second wave of kobit 19.
both her parents are covet positive and
her father has been in the hospital for
days
personally for me it's been an emotional
mayhem in this second wave my dad became
a victim
and a very serious one and it just made
me realize
how crazy things are at the moment
kanika runs an online mental health
platform mind peers
which connects people to therapists
and the statistics are enough to tell
her that she is not alone
apart from anxiety depression and grief
that many are already experiencing
she says a lot of young people may end
up suffering with ptsd
or post-traumatic stress disorder last
year
there were about 50 to 60 therapies that
were coming in
in one day and right now from the last
three to four weeks at least that has
touched 250 or a day
the second wave has been catastrophic
images of people gasping for breath
and collapsing in front of hospitals
where no beds or oxygen are available
have impacted the mental well-being of
many
some experts are convinced this wave has
triggered a mental health epidemic of
its own
we can now speak to dr samir parrik who
joins us from gurugram near delhi he
leads the department
of mental health and behavioral sciences
at fortis
healthcare thanks for joining us we've
just been hearing from indians
particularly young indians talking about
their struggles with their mental health
during this pandemic
is the health care provision there for
people to seek help
two aspects to this uh in
any case mental health prevalence if you
look worldwide
right depression single largest illness
300 million people globally suffering
from it
we in any case have more than 500
shortage of mental experts in our
country
that is pre-coped now what we need to
understand is
that yes more conversations will be
happening around mental health
lot more than four people are talking
about mental health
so mental health services or provisions
are not merely about experts and
expertization when
it comes to our part of the world it
will also involve
the family support friends social media
communicating with your primary
physicians and at
multiple levels the kind of psychosocial
support and guidance
that's what we are working with right
now
you mentioned help coming i suppose from
within communities rather than
necessarily from
healthcare professionals but one of the
things about india is that it's
enormously
diverse does that make it challenging to
ensure that all groups are getting the
sort of help that they need
but that's an obvious i mean
even if you look at it and again i i
need to use the pre-covered example
because it gives the context to it
that we largely have most experts
of belonging to the mental health
fraternity in urban india
and as you move down to rural india
the percentage of experts would come
down
so what happens is that accessibility
reduces the moment accessibility reduces
naturally there is more stigma there is
more stereotyping
there is more discrimination there are
more struggles because help is not
available
i mean it could be something as simple
as let's say having an episode of
anxiety
and needing a certain form of expertise
both in terms of guidance or medications
so yes it does make it difficult but at
the same time
i must say this that right at the start
of covent once telemedicine was allowed
in our country what it has
shown all of us is that digital
interface and telemedicine
is probably going to be in years to come
a more long-term solution for a diverse
diverse country like ours
because you may have somebody sitting
miles away
not having an expert for also miles you
can now
adjust a click of a button get an expert
advice medications counseling
sitting within the premises where they
are because of the internet access and i
think that's the transition
that kovid is bringing and i i truly
believe that in years to come
the digital interface is going to bridge
the various gaps we have in mental
health services
another change that you mentioned just
earlier was that
people are talking more about mental
health now than before earlier in the
program we mentioned
a campaign by uh deepika deepak padukone
who's
an actor who's been talking about her
own experiences of mental health
is it possible that a positive change in
attitudes could come as a result of the
pandemic
the difficult one to answer isn't that
uh
at one level i feel um
sad that would we need a pandemic
to uh bring more conversations around
mental health
mental health conversations have been
increasing over the past decade or not
the example if you you gave of a very
well known celebrity is a conversation
which is
a few years now so it's not during
copenhagen she's been talking about it
much earlier
and when more and more people start
talking about mental health issues the
fact that they have taken help
it does have an impact we have to accept
that role models and influencers
have an immense impact especially on the
young population that that that's an
absolute fact
i think what's happening during coven is
that
an individual may not realize that they
are talking about mental health but
it is mental health that's been
addressed for example
the fear of getting an illness or the
fear of what if something happens to
your family
fear of getting treatment on time
all of these anxieties and fear and
stresses
like examinations uh results
jobs economy all of these psychosocial
factors
do give stress so when people start
talking about it
in a way that's also primary
intervention of mental health
because rather than bottling it up you
are talking about it because you realize
it's not universal right a pandemic is a
pandemic because it is pan
so now relatedness about distress
is easier so unmuting sharing
about it has become more spontaneous
and which i think is also in a way an
intervention for a country like ours
because like i've been saying
expertisation is not the solution the
strength of india always have been
in its interdependent
family system social system
so the more connected engaged
and communication that happens
in this dissociative milieu which is the
strength
which is out of all these diversities
that we have
that continues to be a strengthy family
system right so the more this
interaction increases
you know automatically your first level
of mental health intervention is
happening
sure so india's vastness is uh
in this case perhaps its strength dr
samir parikh from fortis healthcare has
been fascinating
here what you've had to say thanks for
joining us
thank you now it's time to answer
another
another of the questions you've been
sending into us today's
is also about the effect of the
coronavirus on the mind
over to our science correspondent derek
williams
what are the neurological symptoms
associated with covid19
and long covid covid19 can affect
different people in in very different
ways and
and a certain number of those who
contract it develop
neurological symptoms by some
calculations actually a lot more people
experience them
than than people who don't in the active
phase of the illness
those symptoms can include dizziness
confusion
tingling or numb extremities a loss
of smell and taste and in more serious
cases
delirium seizures and stroke
doctors say the neurological symptoms
could be caused by a number of factors
in patients who have serious respiratory
distress for instance
oxygen deprivation in the brain can play
a key role
but but an out-of-control immune
response
could also contribute to symptoms and in
some patients at least
the virus appears to also directly
infect the brain or nerves and some
symptoms
can persist or or even first appear
after survivors have supposedly
recovered from covid19 as an aspect of
this
still undefined condition often
generically called
long covet a recent large-scale
study looking at a wide range of
neurological
and psychiatric outcomes in patients
six months after infection found that
around
one in three had complaints in those
areas
most often anxiety or mood disorders so
what are generally
classified as mental health
issues and although there was some
correlation
with disease severity with with people
who had bad
cases of covet 19 more likely to suffer
serious neurological complaints
many long-term symptoms were also far
from uncommon
in people who had moderate cases of the
disease
[Music]
you